you are listening to the most original
talk radio station and win we are la
talk radio at la talk radio com
listening to phil
courage Willie
and caring
we talk radio now you have the training
yeah how are you booking the work you
know I'd like night now you're back at
Ground Zero yeah what steps are you
taking to get to get those first jobs
that's catch-22 because uh I have no
real and you know it's I'm trying to get
out there get an agent and to let me see
you real I don't got one you know I mean
let me see it I got a headshot you know
you take 50 million heads out to people
and you know if so it's hard so what I
started doing was I was like I I'm gonna
make this happen I'll make my own real
you know so I said let me put together a
short film or something where I could be
in it and cut that together to use as my
real so started doing some network with
some friends and try and get something
together and put together uh my first
short film basically and it did really
well they started winning some festivals
and getting a lot of recognition and
with that you know some was like hey man
do you want help me produce this thing
and so I wound up doing a bunch of short
films some music videos couple
commercials I started getting paid for
some of the stuff you know especially
the commercials it was like man this is
pretty I don't want to say easy but
something that falls into my realm of
networking and putting stuff together so
I started producing stuff and then
started working on some independent
films and helping them out with them and
then people like hey do you want to help
us produce this cuz you know you got it
going on I'm like sure do I still get
that do my acting part no yeah so you
know next thing you know it's like I'm
gonna produce man I give myself parts
give my friends parts you know get my
friends jobs and that's basically how it
started in a short